let's think a little bit about the labor
market and in all of these videos
whether we're talking about renting
units or hiring people these are huge
oversimplifications but we're doing it
this way so we can apply some of these
basic basic ideas that we're being
exposed to in this kind of survey of
microeconomics so that we can apply
those basic ideas to kind of real world
things but it's important to realize
we're making huge oversimplifications
and oftentimes the real context can be
more complicated or a little bit nuanced
but it gives us a way of thinking about
things so this is the unskilled labor
market so people who don't have any
specific training or experience for a
given job the vertical axis is their
wage rate per hour it's essentially the
price of labor this little gap here
shows i started at zero but then i
jumped up to five six
and this right here is a quantity of
labor and we're measuring that in terms
of millions of hours per month and once
again we have this little gap here so we
can jump to 20 20 million hours 21
million hours it's important to realize
when we think about demand in the labor
market
we're not talking about individual
consumers we're talking about employers
in most cases demand comes from
individual consumers but now the demand
is coming from employers these are the
people who are essentially buying labor
and the supply is not coming from
corporations the supply is coming from
the people who provide labor so now it's
coming from individual workers
so now it is coming from workers so
let's just say
that this market starts off being
completely unregulated and so it has a
natural equilibrium equilibrium price or
equilibrium range at six dollars or
equilibrium wage at six dollars an hour
and an equilibrium quantity of labor
supplied which is 22
22 millions of hours per month
but let's say the government in this
this hypothetical city or country says
you know what
six dollars is a really low wage we have
trouble imagining how people live well
off of a six dollar an hour wage so they
say that this right over here is too low
the government does not like it and
maybe many of their voters are people
making that wage so they say hey you
know what we are going to pass some
well-intentioned legislation we are
going to pass a minimum wage
we are going to pass a law
minimum wage that says any employer has
to pay at least at least seven dollars
an hour
seven dollars an hour so it has to be at
least seven dollars an hour so this
right over here is a price
this is a price floor this is a minimum
price in the market when we talked about
rent control that was a price ceiling
that was a maximum price for rent now
this is a minimum price for labor and
what since the price floor this minimum
price is higher than the actual clearing
price it's going to distort the market
so our price floor is right over here
seven dollars so this right over here is
our minimum wage so this right over here
is our minimum wage so what's going to
happen here well if you look at the
demand side of things the employers are
going to say wow if i have to pay seven
dollars an hour now i can only afford 21
million hours of labor so they're going
to say i can only afford now 21 million
hours of labor
but if you look at the if you look at
the workers they're going to be they're
going to say gee if i can if i can make
seven dollars an hour if i can make
seven dollars an hour then i more people
are going to be willing to work either
an individual might say well like if i
was working 40 hours a week making six
dollars an hour if i'm making seven
dollars an hour i'm willing to make work
45 hours a week or there might be a
student who's on the fence who says wow
now wages have gone up enough that it
makes sense for me to work there might
be a maybe someone who's retired and now
at six dollars wasn't enough for them to
come out of retirement but seven dollars
is maybe a stay-at-home parent now says
seven dollars is enough for them to come
out of retirement or not stay at home
anymore and so it actually the labor the
supply the quantity supplied of labor in
terms of hours will increase
and so at seven dollars an hour people
will be willing to supply
that much labor but what's going to
happen what's going to happen in this
situation right over here well in this
situation you have all these people who
want to work but there's only demand for
this much work
so this is right here this is going to
be an oversupply of labor
over supply of labor so another way to
think about it there's only jobs for 21
million people now and now 23 million
people want to work for you so you're
going to have 2 million people who are
by the classical definition of
unemployed people who are looking for
work who can't find work now and once
again this is completely oversimplified
because at this point right over here
based on the way i just viewed that you
would have no unemployment and we all
know even when the economy is humming
maximally and there's no regulation
there is some unemployment just due to
frictions in the market people just
randomly quitting jobs or firing getting
or or looking for a new job but so you
could almost view this as excess
unemployment or you could view this as
just a very oversimplified model and in
the ideal world you get close to zero
unemployment now you have more people
looking for jobs and you because the
wages have gone but fewer jobs because
the employers are forced to pay more
if we make all the assumptions in the
model you just want to say how many
fewer jobs are there because this
obviously we're talking about more
people even looking for jobs because the
perceived wages have gone up but in the
absolute level if you you know based on
these these linear supply and demand
curves before there was demand for 22
million jobs and that was actually where
this or the quantity demanded was and
that's also where the quantity supplied
was but now it's only 21 million so
based on this model you're going to have
1 million 1 million fewer jobs 1 million
fewer jobs now when you think about it
in terms of surplus so before the
minimum wage the entire surplus
was this entire area over here so
this entire area that's below the demand
curve and above the supply curve this
entire was a total surplus and it was
being divided between the consumer
surplus and the producer surplus so this
right over here so the between the price
and the supply curve was the producer
surplus and the producer surplus
remember the producers of labor are the
individual workers so this was the
benefit above and beyond the opportunity
cost that the workers were getting was
this area right over here that i'm doing
kind of in dark white or filled in white
and the consumer surplus or the employer
surplus year
was the value that the employers were
getting the value that the employers
were getting above and beyond the price
that they had to pay
now in this situation of a minimum wage
now this is the set price this is the
quantity of labor that is demanded and
so what you lose now the surplus that we
lose is this quantity right over here
this quantity
right over here and we could figure out
that area quite easily let's see this
this height right over here is 1 million
hours per month so it's going to be
1 million i'll just write 1 for we'll
just remember it's on millions times
this height
times this height right over here which
is two dollars per hour so times two
times one half if we just multiply these
we get this whole rectangle for the area
of the triangle we multiply it times one
half
times one half that gives us that
cancels out that gives us exactly one
and the units are dollars per hour times
millions of hours per month
gives us dollar millions of dollars per
month so it becomes one million dollars
one million dollars per month
of of surplus of benefit
of of benefit above and beyond
of total benefit that is lost to this
market because of this regulation if you
if you assume all of the things in this
model so just like we talked about in
the last video we have a one million
dollar per month deadweight loss
dead weight
deadweight loss now not everyone loses
here because the price was set up
because the price is set up over here
for the people who are working those
though those first 21 million hours per
month there could their producer surplus
has now increased because the space
between what they're getting and their
opportunity cost has now increased so
for those lucky enough to produce to
actually have a job they are those
workers now do have a higher surplus but
for those and for those employers which
is on the demand side right now their
surplus who who are employing those
first 21 million
hours of labor they now have a smaller
have a have a smaller consumer surplus
or demand surplus or employer surplus
right there so for the first for the
first 21 million units of labor it is it
is it's redistributing the pie between
the employers and the workers but then
because you are making the the wage
higher it's reducing the overall demand
so there is if you believe this model
some job destruction taking place